we have adopted conclusions today both
the presidency and the council wanted to
have short focused and ambitious
conclusions and they got it firstly
supports to SMEs startups and innovative
businesses as a meez are the backbone of
our economy and need more of our
attention and help and secondly
improvement of surfaces markets
including the services passport Member
States discuss how the new tool
announced by the Commission should be
developed and we want to make it easier
for businesses to provide surface
cross-border and we want to tackle
barriers which prevents full use of the
single market first we asked the
Commission to reduce the time needed for
anti-dumping investigations by at least
two months without jeopardizing the
quality of these investigations this
would allow for swift action when
products are dumped on the European
steel market this would certainly help
our steel and other energy-intensive
industries stay competitive in the short
term second we want to keep
energy-intensive industries including
our steel industries competitive in the
longer term we believe it's vital to
take the next step in energy efficiency
and the transition to a low-carbon
economy by enhancing innovation for
instance through the use of pest and
Yonkers European fund for strategic
investments we can surely improve the
competitiveness of this sector thirdly
we called for concrete measures at a
European level in order to reduce
regulatory costs and emission to a
system related costs in particular for
best performing companies such measures
could significantly contribute to a
global level playing field for our
industries the three major point for me
was first one of course the council
conclusion on conclusions on the single
market strategy this is an important
step in our world I think that all along
with upcoming resolution of the European
Parliament today's come to the
conclusion will play an important role
they our debate focused above all on
barriers to quote cross-border
provisions of services so
services passport and I want to tell you
that I was really super even surprised
that the support for the for our
initiative and support for our approach
to the services passport what was much
rather than I expected of course member
states are divided on scope and speed of
the document but everything will be
deciding in the course of this year we
agreed that the pass for must make it
significantly easier for service
providers to operate cross borders